- Marc-Antoine Roy met tout
en place pour accueillir
d'éducation physique à l'écoleS,
en Côte-Nord. L'enseignant
l'épaule à la roue pour contrer
la pénurie de main-d'oeuvre
enseignante qui frappe
durement
MARC-ANTOINE ROY,
enseignant d'éducaque
- Moi, c'était pour aider
les enfants. Ce que je veux,
quand ils sortent de chez eux,
trouvent un moyen de s'amuse
en faisant de l'activité
physique.
- Entrique policière, il est
ce qu'on appelle un enseignantn.
Marc-Antoine n'a ni brevet
ni diplôme en enseignement.
scolaire de l'Estuaire
- Qu'on soit sur lord,
sur la Rive-Sud, à Montréal,
à Québec, le problème,
on a une pénurie
de main-d'oeuvre criante.
- Tellement criante que
le recours à ces enseignants
non qualifiés en p la dernière
année scolaire, selon des
obtenues par Radio-
Canada. En 10 ans, il a même
explosé. Plus de 3400 tolérances
à des enseignants non qualifiés
en 2021 : du jamais-vu.
GENEVIÈVE SIROIS, professeure,
- Ça ne constitue qu'une infime
part du nombre d'ets
non légalement qualifiés
qu'il y a dans notre réseau.
- Cette chercheuse estime
qu'ils seraient en fait 10 fois
plus nombreux, et près de
30 000 à enseigner à nos enfants
ir de diplôme
en enseignement puisque rien
scolaires à faire une demande
de tolérde tolérde tolérde tolée
de l'Éducation.
ils sont là par choix.
Donc donles moyens
de se qualifier, d'avoir la
formation dont ils ont besoin.
proposée par plusieurs :
rmation universitaire
accélérée plutôt que les quatre
années de bac actuelles.
au bureau, mais maintenant,
e à l'école!
- Après une maitrise
en marketing et 15 anslentine Pd
a changé de cap l'an dernier.Lae
au primaire. Impossible
pour elle de se enseignante au
primaire Centre Marie-Victorin
- Perdre un salaire pendant
quatre ans, ce n'est pas
envisageusement. Mais j'ai envie
de le faire, ce métier.
C'est pour ça que je me donne.
- Le ministre de l'Éducation,
Jean-Fradit pourdit pourdit pous
pour contrer la pénurie
de main-d'oeuvre enseignante
et compte créer plus de places
dans les programmes
aux titulaires de baccalauréat
de se qualifier à titre
d'enseignant, mais le ministre
ne fixe toujours pas
d'échéancier à court terme
poursuivre l'enseignement
tant que la passion l'habite
- Pour moi, c'est ça ma paie,
c'est ça, ma récompense. C'estr.
apprentissages en continu
pour améliorer ses qualités
Ici Jérôme Bergeron,
Radio-C